en trois français sont morts dus
coronavirus la france donc demeure le
deuxième foyer de l'épidémie en europe
voilà qui inquiète et occupent donc les
conversations alors sur twitter facebook
instagram
on se rend compte rapidement de
l'importance accordée au sujet quand on
voit les millions de tweets depuis 30
jours
c'est donc plus de quatre millions avec
ce hashtag coronavirus et par
comparaison pour construire bien compte
les municipales c'est 800 mille cécité
seulement huit cent mille fois à peu
près voyez aussi ex qui s'affiche à
l'écran là c'est un nuage de mots c'est
ce qui ressort le plus sur twitter
aujourd'hui on parle surtout de la
presse alors vous voyez stratégies de
dépistage
on pense probablement en comparaison
avec les autres pays suspicion
coronavirus moyens nécessaires on voit
aussi le mot stade qui ressort
certainement rapport stade de stade iii
alors est-ce qu'on va vers le pire ce
que vous pensez qu'on va vers le pire ou
est ce que vous trouvez qu'on est devenu
un peu fou je le disais en introduction
c'est justement pour rassurer les
français que le chef de l'état
s'exprimera demain à 20 heures
denis tillinac est ce que vous diriez
comme gérald bronner ce matin dans les
colonnes du figaro que l' on surestime
le risque c'est à dire qu'on est devenu
un peu irrationnel
quand le niveau du risque j'ai pas les
compétences pour maël pour en décider
ce qui est évident c'est que l'on
nourrit une espèce de psychose collectif
qui va retrouver retrouver dans quelque
part dans l'inconscient viande et de
très vieux fantasme avec cette
effervescence médiatique permanente tous
les titres les télés toutes les radios
donc on parle que de ça hors jeu vers 2
je viens de chez moi en corrèze où
chansons ordinaires
c'est pas comme dans ce micro climat
parisien sûr on n'en parle pas beaucoup
on s'embrasse on serre la main on se
lave les mains de temps en temps mais je
dire on n'a pas l'impression que ces
consignes ramon dans le centre ville on
a
un cahier du monde en centre-ville et
j'en avais biteau mais j'ai pris mon
train hier tout le monde vivait
normalement fait rêver dans une soirée
avec des amis nombreux dans un
restaurant tous embrasser serrait la
main et le restaurant était plein j'ai
dû me demande si les politiques les
journalistes
à l'intérieur de ce micro univers
m'arrive de fréquenter quand je manque
d'intérêt vous n'êtes pas en train de
vous intoxiquer un peu quoi faut il
donner l'adresse du restaurant vous
laissiez par contre on y avait autour
janvier perdant son histoire parisienne
le navire moi je ne crois pas ce soir et
pas de valeur du corps j'ai dit que pour
les aider il ya une dimension de
psychose collective
je crois qu'il ya ça on en effet la
psychose de collectifs en même temps
parce que je crois c'est intéressant
c'est vrai qu'on dit souvent tient le
gouvernement sur réagit et en même temps
aussi on est dans une époque où il ya
tellement de faits que news que s'il ne
réagissait pas on imagine très bien ce
qu'il pouvait y avoir derrière c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya eu d'autres
carreaux souvient de la canicule quand
on a pris ça avec un petit peu vraiment
un peu de recul et puis finalement on
n'y a été là moi je trouve ça
intéressant en fait un objet de
sur-réagir pas pour faire face à tout
simplement la presse fasse élire leurs
proches
on n'a peut-être pas assez agi on n'a
peut-être pas été assez fort et bien là
tout simplement il ya c'est sûr que
c'est pas très joyeux d'entendre tous
les soirs quelqu'un derrière un pupitre
annoncé le nombre de contaminés et non
de victimes mais je pense que dans
l'époque actuelle c'est nécessaire on va
se poser la question du rôle des médias
dans cette crise sanitaire
mais juste avant je voudrais qu'on
écoute le professeur delfraissy il était
ce matin sur france inter
il répondait lui à une médecin qui
dénonçait la psychose ambiante induite
pour elle par les médias la formation
est un élément clé pour essayer de
garder la confiance parce que vis-à-vis
de la société civile tout l'enjeu c'est
de garder la confiance c'est comment des
mesures difficiles prises au niveau
politique et gouvernemental s'appuyant
sur des données médicales et
scientifiques aussi solide qu'on peut
les avoir mais avec un grand degré
d'incertitude avec un grand degré
d'incertitude que j'assume
comment arriver à garder la confiance
vis-à-vis de nos citoyens
donc l'information c'est important pour
garder la confiance
jean pierre rosenberg est ce que vous
diriez que les médias en font trop
j'ai jamais dit ça sur ma sur aucun
sujet le joueur n'aura plus de meilleur
en aura de sacrés problèmes si vous le
voulez non je comprends qu il est un
petit peu différent que dès que vous
voyez ce que nous avons vu sur la chine
est ce que dans l'histoire nous nos
tristes pas mon histoire vivante est
encore jeune j'ai jamais vu un pays qui
confinait des millions et des millions
de personnes
en d'autres termes les autorités
chinoises ont laissé à penser qu'ils
avaient quelque chose qui était
gravissime qui est en train de se jouer
avec l'économie - on sait avec
l'économie chinoise qui a été impactée
ni attenant ça doit se dire que
l'économie mondiale est impactée c'est
pas les médias concret et ça c'est un
fait même pardon de vous couper rage ils
gagnent troubles les autorités chinoises
ont commencé par emprisonnés le médecin
qui donne l alerte totale sur les
chinois de cette précis bilité non mais
oui c'est cause au contraire ils ont
freiné week envisagent ils ont freiné
autant qu'ils ont quand vous arrêter
quelqu'un qui danse quelque chose au
crir mon avis encore plus d'angoissé
parce qu'on a voulu un moment donné et
atteindre quelque chose puis ensuite on
l'a mis aux granges et puis on a pris
des mesures
car ce qui se passe en italie ou encore
jamais vu nulle part c'est à des médias
qui ont inventé ça alors c'est une
réalité
maintenant oui à force d'en parler en
boucle tout le temps sur les chaînes
d'info n'alimente ce que disait le
médecin bien sûr qu'on y contribue t il
à poulou et la poule où elle offre en
finit par ne plus savoir
reste qu'à une stratégie qui est
développé par le gouvernement qui est de
retarder la le pic d'épidémie pour ne
pas j'allais dire que tous les malades
le même jour se retrouver entre personne
de nick c'est une une maladie j'ai dire
qui est faramineuse et qui va tuer
énormément je crois que important plus
que pour la grippe
moi ce qui me préoccupe c'est
qu'actuellement les 26 morts en france
malheureusement et de voir qu'un
assistant droite 33
mais cannes à 6 ans et quelque 700 en
italie donc il ya une stratégie qui est
développé par les par les pouvoirs
publics français pour retarder et
d'essai plus possible pic de grippe etc
le pi 2
le pli de corps qu'on aura venus donc je
pense qu'effectivement le la politique
publique est très dur à expliquer si
vous levez en l'état parce
qu'effectivement il ya des comportements
anxiogène il ya tous les mails et
j'allais repartir les images que les
gens voient sur ce qui se passera en
chine et c'est aussi en italie il ya
effectivement de quoi être anxieux à mon
avis de manière excessive parce que
somme toute on va avoir quelque chose
qui a raté arrêter l'équivalent d'une
grande épine et médéric encore que soit
faire ma part en 1911 la grande épidémie
grippale a tué bien plus on ne pourra
jamais tuer le corona vide et la grippe
ordinaire tue chaque année encore des
d'entre eux dit sérieuse mais pas cette
année comme tous les ans franck ferrand
livrer cette réflexion le confirme
journaliste et historien livrer cette
réflexion dans le figaro lundi dans les
colonnes du figaro disait pour la
première fois sans doute avec cette
crise du cours d'un virus la réflexion
politique s'est mise au diapason de la
frénésie médiatique les chaînes d'info
en fait dit les chaînes en fonte
imposaient leur rythme aux médecins qui
doivent délivrer analyse sur analyse
toute la journée à tour de bras
le point presse tous les soirs des
hommes politiques judith est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec cette analyse
oui le papier très bon d'ailleurs je le
conseille à tous nos internautes
en fait il dit à la fois qu'il y à un
emballement politico-médiatique et que
c'est absolument inévitable étant donné
le rythme des médias l'angoissé et qui
existent pas ça virus qui est inconnu
et ça aussi c'est une donnée qui partent
aujourd'hui personne ne sait qui parti
qui vient de chine et accessoirement qui
participe beaucoup à l' angoisse des
gens donc il ya ce rythme dédié à la
surinformation joie au principe de
précaution qui est une notion
relativement nouvelle c'est jacques
chirac qui l'avait introduite dans notre
constitution principe de précaution qui
peut mener aux choses les plus saines ou
je trouve dans déplaise à denis tillinac
dans une ambiance comme celle là c'est
pas très grave ne pas serrer la main et
se faire la bise ou et c'est plutôt
mieux ça peut éviter
le ridicule à mode de contamination
j'aime bien à braver les interdits mais
je trouve pas ça très excitant
en l'occurrence châtellerault 10 voix
donc on va donc le principe de
précaution peut justifier et amener
chacun à adopter légaux comportement de
bon sens mais il a aussi son revers qui
est que quand les politiques se
l'appliquer à eux-mêmes
on arrive tout de suite à une surenchère
parce que les politiques sont forcément
gagnant quoi qu'il arrive six ans pris
trop de précautions c'est pas grave on
va pas leur reprocher l'absence de mort
est comme une île ils en ont pris
beaucoup et s'il emprunte beaucoup et
qui a effectivement beaucoup de victimes
on dira voilà quelqu'un qui a agi avec
les continents ses raisons donc tout ça
pousse à la surenchère cij qui nous
regardent tout moment pardon si jeu qui
nous regardent souvent sur lefigaro.fr
nous dit il vous fait un clin d'oeil
2006 lina qui me dit je vis dans le
limousin padre d'une ville dans les
magasins pas de psychose et il rajoute
2005 rajoute ne devrait-on pas protéger
les personnes à risque et laisser vivre
normalement les autres c'est déjà
aujourd'hui il ya des visites dans les
ehpad sont interdites par le biais de la
santé donc déjà il ya quand même des
premières mesures qui sont prises mais
c'est vrai que moi parce que j'ai trouvé
pour aller dans votre sens assez
impressionnant c'est quand même l'italie
c'est de notre voisin premier enfin
autre nos voisins on qu'on connaît très
bien payé comme ça et on voit à quel
point là c'est un système de santé qui
est vraiment défaillant et qui n'a pas
pu ou su prendre en compte et sa
population
et c'est là où c'est assez dramatique on
voit quand même que parce que parme en
espagne en espagne sur un peu inquiets
pour leurs services mais pour l'instant
ça se passe plutôt bien donc c'était
vraiment le cas de l'italie et
malheureusement c'est un test grandeur
nature sur la bonne santé des services
de santé dont nous était ce matin sur
notre antenne avec le professeur cadre
c'est le cadre d épidémiologie donc qui
disait que le système de santé des
italiens et français étaient à peu près
les mêmes que l'heure était aussi bon
mais que simplement et à retard dans les
prises de décisions politiques critères
si notre système est aussi bon que leur
on doit être inquiet pour les trois
semaines qui viennent un peu supérieure
et que deuxièmement ce que vous oubliez
pas qu on sorte alors oui si on est
toujours dedans mais une crise sur
l'hôpital en général les urgences en
particulier donc ayant la stratégie qui
consiste à retarder la montée en
puissance d'accord est plutôt une bonne
stratégie avec quelques précautions à
prendre
mais effectivement il faut pas aller
jusqu'à des mesures aussi extrêmes ou
alors là ça devient la psychose enfin
bon je la peur jean mathieu pernin avant
de conclure ce sujet est ce que vous
nous raconter surtout aux internautes
comment vous faites le choix de vos
sujets le matin comment vous vous dites
le matin en arrivant à t elle je parle
sous quel angle bas en ce moment en ce
moment et pas de choix comme la lune
tout à l'heure des figures magazine en
fait les ongles je pense que nous tous
ça fait un peu compliqué de trouver des
angles
parce que je pense qu'on est en train de
tous les faire le but en fait ce n'est
pas d'exciter la population c'est pas du
tout ça c'est d'informer alors après il
ya certains médias c'est sûr quand
quelqu'un tousse dans le morbihan on
fait une émission spéciale ben là c'est
bien compliqué après sur des médias plus
généralistes comme les nôtres ou mois
sur lequel je travaille
eh bien on va aller dans chaque cas de
la société par exemple en ce moment il
ya eu cette semaine
énormément de points sur l'économie
l'économie ça a été notamment quand on a
vu par exemple ces avions qui volaient à
vide pour garder des couloirs aériens en
découvre des choses assez incroyables où
quand on voit ce monde du spectacle qui
a eu l'année dernière et gilet jaune
ensuite la crise des transports la grève
des transports et maintenant le
coronavirus on se rend compte que là il
ya un point de vue économique et
difficile et ensuite c'est un point de
vue aussi environnemental qui est assez
étonnant qu'on commence à voir
maintenant dire que tout le monde
s'intéresse à l'environnement
mais quand ça va reprendre la croissance
pas tout le monde va s'en fiche parce
qu'il va falloir y aller à fond de
nouveau et là il va y avoir des
émissions de carbone beaucoup plus
importante donc il ya énormément de
choses ça touche tous les domaines et
même le football voyez ce soir paris
saint germain joue à huis clos et
comment aujourd'hui on peut traiter ça
le renvoyer jz il y aura des supporters
autour des actions qui feront mal sûr a
dit souvent ça sera ça sera bien à peu
près pareil il faut rappeler une règle
simple que des biens c'est que quand nos
lecteurs ou auditeurs de téléspectateurs
trouvent qu'on ravages que la formation
qu'on donne n'a aucun intérêt et sature
nous font savoir
je m'arrête de luire il arrête de tout
est là ce n'est pas le cas et écouter on
pose la question depuis tout à l'heure
sur twitter à tous ceux qui nous
regardent aux internautes c'était un
sondage selon voit-on surestimé le
risque du coronavirus et 60% d'entre
nous disent que nous donc voilà on a
envie d'être informée on a envie de
savoir et on clique sur les articles qui
est souvent menacé par rapport aux
élections municipales par exemple je
pense que beaucoup de gens aussi qui se
pose la question si c'était un label
tour dimanche
il ya là il y aura plus de dans cette
valse tenir c est ce qu il y avait ce
qu'il appelait abstentions voilà un peu
plus peut-être cette jeune formation
j'entendais mon nom une certitude part
parce que vous disiez c'est que des
problèmes qui étaient plutôt enfouis là
avant le coronavirus vont revenir en
première intention par exemple la
dépendance ou ennemis la dépendance sur
les médicaments sur la dépendance sur
ceci est quelque part il va y avoir la
dcn d'avoir d'autres stratégies privée
et publication sur nombre de points
notamment la relocalisation part
d'entreprises chose comme ça vous dites
comme bruno le maire est mise de
l'économie il y aura un avant et un
après j'ai quarante chercher qu'il avait
dit mais je pense qu'on peut penser
comme les financières de 2008 et dans
tout les mois mémoire et qu'aujourd'hui
l'argent qui est mis massivement
massivement qu'on soit créé non
seulement à lutter contre coronavirus
mais aussi à essayer de limiter au
maximum les dégâts économiques que ça
fait ça c'est une leçon